[Music]
the supersoul just running loose
great i got a vibranium all
right i could take them hello girl kick
yours
let me hear you our country is
vulnerable we need new
heroes get in that's not happening
why didn't you use the metal on i don't
always think of it immediately i'm
right-handed now streaming only on
disney plus
today we're here to honor the legacy
symbols are nothing without the women
and men that give them meaning
we need new heroes the falcon and the
winter soldier is relevant and gripping
in all the right ways
marvel has brought feature film caliber
storytelling to disney plus
superheroes cannot be allowed to exist
original series now streaming only on
disney plus
sam shouldn't have given up the shield
good to see you too
buck i have bigger things to worry about
i'm coming with you no you're not
right-handed
original series now streaming only on
disney plus
the last time we see sam and bucky is
after steve
leaves the shield with sam sam is coming
to terms with what it's going to be to
pick up that shield
and that's where we kick off the show
the legacy of that shield is complicated
when disney plus was announced there was
an opportunity to interweave the
cinematic universe with a television
university
the world of the falcon winter soldier
in the film is so big
and you want this show to feel as big
and as engrossing
i think fans will definitely get a kick
out of seeing the continuation of that
kind of
filmmaking that those movies had sam
this has to be subtle got it
the action side is so embedded in what
the mcu
is but through the show we wanted to
look at the human side of the characters
for bucky it's the legacy of the winter
soldier his anchor point to the person
who knew him before he was a murder
machine
no longer exists so bucky feels and more
than the series and is looking for his
purpose and sam wilson is very much
doing the same thing when steve first
told me about the shield the first words
i said were
feels like it's someone else's i felt
like we would be
dishonest just on a human level if we
had this black man just accept the
symbol without having
real ambivalence about it with this
series we've been able to give a level
of sincerity and humanity to him you get
a real sense
of what this character sam wilson really
is the notion of what blackness means in
america
ties very much into sam's journey
through the events of the show
there's a fight out there and then
there's our fight here and bro you have
taken them both on
[Music]
let's get to work
the scope of these six episodes is
really amazing i mean it's a huge story
falcon and winter soldier aren't really
vibrant and electric characters
so when you are thrust into the action
you sink into the narrative and where
the story ultimately goes
you